NSA leaker Edward Snowden is a menace no
not because he passed along information
about classified surveillance programs
in the press that sort of awesome no
he's a menace because he gives the press
an excuse to trot out the graphics and
cutaways they always used to signify
computer usage I mean look at this now I
understand it's not easy to make
encrypted files and data transfers seem
interesting and cool especially when
some of your viewership SMO stre --scent
brush with technology was when an AOL
disc fell out of their time magazine in
1997 but this is obscene now cables
pointer icons and elaborately name
buttons
ones and zeroes just like in the matrix
remember and that tried-and-true standby
hands on a keyboard and it's not like
the movies where truth really comes from
do much better let's see here you've got
your preposterous 3d visualizations of
hacking
you've got your meaningless fuselage of
techno babble I'll create a GUI
interface using visual basic see if I
can track an IP address and yes my
personal favorite it's moving to that
too people using a keyboard
simultaneously to fight off a hacker in
some other locations databases that's
not how typing works Hollywood
discovered the scary internet in the mid
nineteen ninety
and they still haven't gotten it right
trust me America you do not want me is
your anchorman you couldn't handle it
what do you hate about the way the news
media covers technology drop the ax line
in the comments